hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play eyes now
you may be going to wait a minute I
think I've seen this game before you
have but people have been shouting at me
literally shouting me at me in the
streets I was rocking down in the
grocery groaning look like five okay
anyway so I was like I looked at it and
been updated version 2.0 so since I
played scp-432 the up Davers I figured I
deserve her I deserve I deserve could
just try it deserves my gritty inari so
I deserve to give it another try since
before it wasn't exactly scary I want to
I want to go I'm gonna get people have
been saying it's like dude so terrifying
but to me I found the ghost to be oddly
attractive and I'm sure she was just
hunting me down because I was so
devilishly handsome mmm make a map the
places all right blah blah blah I know
this you need to find 24 reader stamina
use the map and amuse your eyes safely
and whatever okay so anyway we're back
in this familiar place it looks quite
similar to what it was before you click
on the environment to open up and you
get these bags the basement key has been
found
first your coke thanks for the note is
the TV gonna go wobbly it did before I
hear some wind is that my love why isn't
the TV going wibbly-wobbly TV didn't go
wiggly wobbly you know I found the key
to the basement so I might as well go
there first
hello baby did you miss me hi are you
there to give me a hug oh you missed me
didn't you okay anyway so what you need
to find 20 of these things and
everything shaking everything's going
weird is this the basement key can I
open this yeah hey I thought there were
more in here I guess not
okay so we're wandering around the dark
and dank basement trying to find bags of
gold because that's legal perfectly
illegal
I mean I don't know how desperate anyone
is to rob some place but if there was a
ghost even the attractive ghost that's
in this game
even if there was a ghost after you or
especially if there was ghosts out of
you why in the world
let's see where she is oh she's in the
basement with me not today I'll meet you
upstairs in the boudoir
[Laughter]
that means the bedroom don't go under
the ladder it's bad luck so far so
nothing I seem to be too prayer for this
I seem to be incredibly all of them but
you all knew that already
we're already up to 11 of 12 hello
Shakey's
I hear you lady I hear you madam oh we
will be together soon
do not you worry worry not your pretty
little head all right I think we've just
about got everything in here I don't
think there's any more in the fridge no
nothing okay all right we're out of here
don't go under the ladder bad luck bad
luck Bree all right last place is
upstairs where we're gonna
oh baby darling why you do that to me
baby I wanted I know I know I know you
just want to get your hands all over me
but seriously baby it can't be like that
I needs must space alright let's go
upstairs first because that seemed to
work better last time because when you
go upstairs um there's a big loop where
you can run through so that she can't
get gahh so you can get away from her
lovely I still don't know what's updated
about the game and so far it seems
exactly like it was before I mean I
don't know I really don't understand why
everyone was so adamant that I played it
curse mash oh I'm so scared
mm-hm oh so I can have happy fun times
with my lady goes dear friend hello you
in here I hear you Oh your voice sounds
so beautiful lady
hello who is slamming the doors more and
more and more I think I think they
definitely reduce excuse me don't be
doing that I think they definitely
reduced the number of bags that spawned
was that did I get something out of that
don't know are the safe combination Oh
what did I just get I picked up
something didn't see what it was though
anyway don't matter I got a safe
combination which means it ah get the
goodies I get these goodies and then I
get more goodies later when me and the
lady friend go go into the boardwalk
okay give me the goodies eight of
there's got to be a little more upstairs
I know that unless it's like they
shorted up so that it was really only a
twenty in the house but I'm pretty sure
there's more than 20 ah this is a
deathtrap I shouldn't have come up here
swarming habló far nah she's gonna get
me something stupid and got stuck up
here I know she's gonna get me where are
you where are you lady lady I hear you
in front of me she's after you they see
this is why I go upstairs first because
it's so easy to get away from her unless
you go into a dead-end room then you're
kind of boned
where did I come from where I come from
where did I go where I come from the ha
oh it's this from again oh my lady come
on in I lit a candle for you I've got
some nice rope here for you
I feel loose I've always I never knew
what that did kevvuu oh I guess he's
gone no sale as a precaution let's go
the other way out cuz there's a stairs
right yeah
now we can go downstairs and not have to
worry about meeting with her I still
don't have the safe key down here so I
might not get 20 even though I'm really
close hello rat you disgusting actually
you know what I actually might get 20 I
don't need to see where she is
I know
she's a rat behind me but I will get her
don't you worry about that Oh get her 16
17 18 19 on a roll
20 we're done here let's go run run
where is she I can't run cuz my stamina
is all gone
run run hello baby are you behind me
didn't think so run what done run what
my beautiful princess what happened to
your body what happened to you oh that
would they changed apparently no tract
out right by the door I could I could
have won easily but what I'll know they
took away the one thing that I loved
about this game her beautiful body ah my
ghost princess she's gone forever I
could have easily won that by the way I
was the stupid tracted cuz I saw her and
I was like I don't right what no no all
right let's beat the game cuz it said in
the updates that there was also
something at the end there so oh she was
so Purdy with her hair well I mean she
has hair now but no she did her ballet
dance and I was so enraptured by her new
amazing physique oh well alright let's
just go
I'm supposed to save my stamina I was
running since the beginning hmm I'm so
sad now I'm so sad save combination what
was this by the way what bring it out of
here
oh it's an I know I need to print an uh
if I could print ready-made eyes why
didn't I start doing that from the
beginning you know what now
oh where is she oh she just went through
that door she's so stupid she's so
stupid I mean I guess when they lost her
body she lost her brains - I didn't make
any sense at all she went down that way
but she failed to see that I was picking
up all of her goodies I don't know what
happened to you lady but I don't like it
please go back to your own natural look
you may not like your body but I loved
it there's nothing to tie up anymore
okay normally I come in take this way
hello hello hello I can't go downstairs
yet I don't have everything all right
whatever I'll go down rat I think I have
enough I might just be able to make it
through depends on how many are down
here well looks like there aren't that
many whatever oh so hurt by this all
right morning
enough being silly Marga boy everyone
knows markiplier 100% serious 100% of
the time we got 16 if I don't get all 20
down here I'm gonna be very upset
oh no do not stop me in 19 I will oh
yeah all right now let's get out of here
unless she's not down here and she's
gonna get me right as I go upstairs
should be fine then ah come on oh come
on I gotta make a loop should be fine
should be fine Oh No I'm floating at is
quite creepy
get out of here lady you can't give me
ah you gotta get me yeah
yeah Oh winner winner chicken dinner aye
congrats man nicely done why didn't you
make old lady really dude really you
feel like there was
oh I'm so sad now those sadder than it
was scary I'm so sad oh man
my beautiful ballet okay I'm done
morning well I played the update I
really would say what added more besides
just changing her model I mean they
decreased some of the bags bonds I think
but so far nothing was really different
in that last scene as a bonus nothing it
was nothing
oh man I would have rat I would have
rather not played it and then just
cruised with that at her being her
beautiful ballet self and her just
wrapping me in her arms and biting my
head off and then we oh and then we
cuddle and then just you know it would
have been nice to have that memory stay
in my mind but now I've got the vision
of her floating head in her lung
tenderly hair damn shame how dare you
everybody how dare you ever everybody
put that image in my head okay thank you
all so much for watching and click the
annotation for more videos it I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]